her best-selling autobiography was made
into a feature film and now there's a
documentary on the life of Bethany
Hamilton the professional surfer is
stopping by right here on the Rich Eisen
show in advance of the film Bethany
Hamilton unstoppable gonna be in the
theater near you this very Friday get to
see you Bethany how's life so you're
here in in Los Angeles big movie
premiere give you had last night Friday
Saturday and yeah just doing a bunch of
media and promoting I appreciate you
stopping by here howdy what's it like to
see a documentary about you watching
that yeah I'm really happy with how the
film captures my life from childhood to
now and even entering into marriage and
motherhood and still continuing my
professional athletic career in surfing
and yeah and it's funny when we first
started the film we were making a ducky
short like just high performance action
surfing women long story short we just
ended up 90 minutes long I mean but how
did that how did that come about I mean
I had met the producer director Aaron
Lieber on another project he was working
with with my friend leekie Peterson
another professional surfer and he saw
me surf and he was blown away and he's
like hey we need to make something just
to show off your surfing like that has
not been shown properly yet so I was
like sure like any reason to go on a
surf trip and just be in the ocean and
pushing myself I was on board so yeah we
just after I got married married I think
I'm coming up on six or seven years now
that's an answer if I gave that answer
you get away with that that would be an
issue my wife knows I love her too but
you know I know it's been I know usually
teen years you know but it's okay
yeah it's been a while it's been a while
for me 16 years amazing
even Manuel Congrats on being married
six or seven years six years of 2013 it
says so do the math let's act like the
last minute hasn't what you've been
surfing your whole life when was the
first time you're from Hawaii correct
born and raised the island of Kauai is
it okay what's the name of your town
yeah when did you first get on a
surfboard I think my parents had me on
the board when I was a baby probably
before I could walk
and just the same with my boys they've
already been out there and my four year
old loves it my 1 year olds ocean stoked
okay okay so you what does that mean
he's okay just you he's like loves
getting in the water though I did take
him on a wave a few days ago
we took off and we're not being filmed
and whatnot and he was like screaming
the whole ride I was like oh gosh bad
timing mom fail I know mom fell a
one-year-old surfing that's amazing that
really sure I'm sure
nowadays you never know people get upset
over every little thing we are seeing
you we are seeing you in the documentary
right now with with your kid how has
being a mother changed you yeah I mean I
think it's created me to be less selfish
and I think that's a beautiful thing and
I also appreciate my time in the ocean
and maximized it when I get out there
and just teaching me patience I'm not
the most patient person that going in
that and well again you know I mean
we're watching you obviously in this
documentary where you're you're you know
you're growing is a person and obviously
as a mom as well I how were you able to
get back in the water after you lost
your arm
losing your arm being bitten by a tiger
shark able to do that she put it simply
I think I'm really just my fear of
losing surfing was greater than my fear
of sharks and I was willing to try I was
willing to give it a go with one arm and
I had talked to the guy by the name of
Mike coots who surfs with one leg and he
lost his leg to a shark and he was like
hey I think you can surf with one arm
and so he was my hint of inspiration and
then once I got up on my first wave
there's no turning back and yeah I was
like the ocean was my oyster and I was
ready to just do whatever I could to be
the best I could on waves do you have
people that come up to you and you know
ask you that question about courage to
try and transfer that to whatever's
going on in their lives do you do you
get that I think a lot of people can
hear my story and they think of their
own you know circumstantial pain or
struggles that they're dealing with and
they find hope and it's really a special
thing to be able to share my story and
encourage others and that's hugely why I
made the documentary was just getting
deeper into the real Bethenny and I had
Soul Surfer like 10 years ago and that
was amazing but this is just the real me
and yeah it goes into motherhood there's
no sports documentaries that I know of
unlike mothers and sports so it has a
lot of unique aspects of capturing the
beauty of the ocean but also me being a
mom and like entering that unknown world
and then continuing to push it yeah I
know it just it was a wonderful shot
Bethany Hamilton here on the Rich Eisen
show after seeing the US Women's
National Team win in France and it just
struck me you know I obviously have seen
Super Bowl champions and and other World
Series champions hugging their sons and
daughters
it just was died I don't know why it
just hit me in my gut seeing some of the
women who were winning just win the
World Cup grabbed their daughters and
sons out of out of the stands you know
they're just obviously something just
some different about motherhood yeah
definitely like yeah that makes me
super stoked to hear that I didn't lay
like realize the good there's mom yes
there are some moms on the song I feel
like soccer is so hard on your body too
- like transfer from after giving birth
and the way the woman's body changes and
all that it goes through and then to
continue push it in a soccer field and
like just the way you're so hard running
and right yeah that's insane to me yeah
I mean that was there again it was just
I don't know if you mentioned motherhood
and and athletes it's just you don't
really stop and think about it very
often yeah and that's all part of
Bethany Hamilton unstoppable which is in
theaters new you on Friday July 12th you
won't you of we were talking about SP
night you won an SB in 2004 right let's
come back early were you there did you
know was when I was receiving it so see
your your for you were 14 when you got
it okay I think so 14 or 15 yeah right
so 2015 because I had won the Nationals
okay that year with one arm right and so
it was like comeback moment you know who
do you remember meeting that night I
really didn't know who anyone was either
cuz I only knew surfing and surfing
world so I'm like with all these amazing
athletes that I'm coaching how about
that where's your SP now kids toy rich I
surf Donna give my one-year-old just the
other day large enough that you might be
able to you know mounted actually just
built I gotta get some decorations doing
and just a little like you know Marie
Kondo like can't have to mention there I
don't know it's gonna make the guy okay
but you also said off the air that there
was another espy award you were up for
that you decided yeah so in my
documentary film part of the thing is
just talking about how I've been known
as like the shark girl and like that
one-arm girl and Britney and all these
like random name
you're just like okay when she could put
some thought into that but I also was up
for an espy nominated for the best you
have a disabled athlete like maybe two
or three years ago and I just didn't
feel like that term suits me as a human
being
I'm so incredibly abled and adaptive and
a go-getter that like I just don't view
myself as disabled and so to me I was
like dang if the category was just
called best adaptive athlete I would be
like incredibly excited to receive that
award interesting did you communicate
that - I did yeah I let them know and
then I just like withdrew because I was
like I don't want to receive this award
and even though I have so much respect
for all the athletes who are incredibly
adaptive in that category I just didn't
feel good about it afraid the
terminology is best female athlete with
a disability espy award so what what you
preferred to be called that's adaptive
athlete okay would be amazing to me and
I just think if I group like woke up
each day thinking while I'm disabled I
can't do stuff like I just think it has
a lot of negative connotations to it so
yeah and I'm just feel like I'm so
incredibly abled like what I do in the
ocean and like just on land like I'm
more able than like the average Joe you
know like no offense like I just think
I'm taken
absolutely none taken so I'm like I
should be the person in that like
airplane exit real like rescuing
everyone opening the door like pushing
it out like getting out of the plane I
mean I wouldn't mind being stranded on
island but yeah I'm gonna ask you a
question we asked of Laird Hamilton when
he was here was the last time you had a
pizza oh actually we had one like three
nights ago
like for real well what did he call a
pizza he said she was like cauliflower
only had true yeah it was a cauliflower
crust or something that was like 10
years ago yeah I am like cheap meals he
may be a little more strict than me but
yeah we ordered a pizza it was like
vegan maybe talk about a deep dish sort
of like real no I understand if I go to
Chicago I will have a whole have a slice
you would yeah when was the last time
you were in Chicago unstoppable in
theaters this Friday go check it out at
Bethany Hamilton on both Twitter and
Instagram thanks for coming on that's on
motherhood Congrats on on the
documentary Congrats on being married
six or seven years and good luck to you
moving forward come back anytime you
wish thank you you got it that's a bring
a suit for next yes now we're talking
decorate the moon now now we're talking
he could use it could definitely use
that sort of future no doubt about it
Bethany Hamilton unstoppable for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app